road to zero
time and place for speed
wai makiruri's matt and nicole
summerfield are new zealand's best-known
brother and sister rallying here
they've been competing at the top end of
rallying since 2010.
[Music]
hi we're met in the color summerfield
and we're from rengura and we compete in
the new zealand rally championship
so in a rally car we have lots of safety
features we've got roll cages we wear
hands devices and helmets and flame
proof gear the everyday car you don't
get that luxury you're not driving
around an overall so that's why it's so
important to stay safe in the car when
you're on the road watching for those
hazards
making sure that you're doing the speed
limit because if you're in a scenario of
a crash
your chances of being injured by not
having those things is a lot higher
when crashes happen there are many
causes
people make mistakes
the road might be tricky the weather
might be bad
the majority of serious crashes are not
from high-risk behaviours but are simply
because someone's made a mistake
in rallying mistakes can happen
whether we are driving too fast or
carrying too much speed around a corner
we know the hazards that are coming up
and on the open road it's very different
you don't know what has it could be
coming towards you so it's very
important to stick to the speed limit
and look out for these hazards and those
speed limits are in place so that you
have enough time to react
we're all just trying to get somewhere
and we should be able to without getting
hurt
everyone should get where they're going
safely your speed may not cause a crash
but it will always determine the outcome
[Music]
you